welcome back if you're in the mood to
break stuff throw things and splash
paint without making a mess at home we
have the place for you rocky is live at
las vegas adrenaline playground having a
smashing good time oh hey rocky
hey jc yeah this is the perfect segue
because i heard you were here a few
years ago this is their brand new
location at town square it's just opened
two months ago but you were here a few
years ago at their other location and
you started smashing before you put your
face cover on you're that excited i
didn't have a visor on you had your
safety all set up rocky you're doing it
right
be careful
yeah yeah i had and when they said that
i was like yep that sounds like jc he
was ready to smash something so now i am
ready denzel but first and foremost i
have to know where do you get the junk
to smash in this in this
in the smash fort i should call it
there's lego there's a lego fort around
us yeah absolutely so we work with
nevada recyclers to make sure they stay
out of the landfills they come to us get
smashed and get recycled right after i
love that okay so this is not just you
know this is not just for fun this is
you know there's some mental health
benefits to this too i would assume 100
so you feel fantastic after you get to
let loose get all those positive
negative feelings to flow out and smash
some stuff so you feel great you've got
a few weapons of choice here you know or
tools of choice i should call them you
got a shovel you got a wrench and you
got what is this chain bat some some
zombie inspiration for us over here so
if you're in the zombie apocalypse
you're ready to go okay well i'm
inspired tell me how to do a coach where
am i going to first so we're going to go
ahead and put our safety gear on i'm
already there and go ahead and let loose
oh my god
for the printer
or whatever that is
lord have mercy
be careful watch your language hitting
these things okay and that was one of
the bigger items but there are some
easier items as well 100 so we have some
bottles right here you can go ahead and
smash those as well
oh this is crazy this is crazy and i
wanna i wanna let you guys know this is
for the entire family but the kids have
to be 10 years or older right yes
correct okay but the paint room we ran
earlier that's for all ages correct okay
last but certainly not least here
i'm gonna go for this
now there's a special technique to the
lamp though right all right just go
ahead get that momentum swing momentum
and watch it break
okay
that one has some like depth to it right
depth to it oh my gosh okay tell
everybody how they can come visit you
guys here in town square your brand new
location yep come find us
simcitysmash.com if you want to make a
reservations walk-ins are included as
well too you can visit us again
citysmash.com or come through with the
town square and come smash some stuff
okay and also you're not just smashing
you know for fun again there's also a
purpose to it tell everybody where 100
so right after we smash everything and
it gets recycled
all the proceeds go to nevada spca to
find
forever homes for our pets in need i
love that and this is a forever home for
some fun
some safe fun okay you guys got to come
down to sin city smash